the new red van trailer for the Hellboy
reboot does a magnificent job of setting
the franchise's new tone revealing a fun
take on Hellboy and the cataclysmic
danger in his world and hinting at some
deeper Hellboy law he has a look at some
of the small details you might have
missed the blazing played that Hellboy
wields on the red band trailer is a
little more than just a cool effect it's
almost certainly meant to be the
mythical blade Excalibur yeah the one
King Arthur carried around in the Wild
Hunt comic book storyline it was
revealed that not only can hell boy
wield Excalibur but he can do so because
he is a descendant of King Arthur and
the true rightful heir of the British
Isles as far as wild reveals go this one
may be one of the wildest in Hell boy
history so it's pretty exciting to see
this moment being presented on the big
screen the Osiris Club a mysterious
organization ripped from the pages of
Hellboy comic books appears in the new
trailer on a hunt for giant asteroid
horseback and decked in some very
Arthurian green and white cupboards led
by a knight wearing the head of a stag
the existence of the Osiris Club in the
film attracts of the appearance of the
villain MOA played by Mila Jovovich it
seems like a sure bet that the movie
will rely pretty heavily on the comics
for plot details meaning this new movie
will be a treat for longtime Hellboy
fans in a blink in your missing moments
eagle-eyed viewers may have caught a
flash of a giant bat like creature
standing in a wrestling ring not only is
this rad but it hints a fan-favorite
one-shot story
Hellboy in Mexico that story details
hull boy getting real with Abe Sapien
about one of the strangest and most
difficult times in his life while in
Mexico in the 1950s he got in deep with
a trio of brothers who also happened to
be Luchadors these Luchadors are more
than your average master wrestlers they
also hunt monsters because they received
a vision from the Virgin Mary
Hellboy joins them on their quest which
entangles him with ancient Mayan temples
and vampire Luchadors a sweet epilogue
gives readers a glimpse into what life
could have been like had Hellboy stopped
hunting monsters donning a mask and
wrestling for the adoration of the crowd
while we probably won't see the whole
tale told in Hellboy
even referencing it among other
adventures will help give viewers a
deeper understanding of the scope of
Hell boys long history of beating up
monsters
since World War two one of the most
striking images and the entire trailer
is the appearance of a house
conspicuously trotting along on a pair
of slender spindly chicken legs that as
you may or may not know is home to none
other than the Baba Yaga
the notorious witch of Eastern European
folklore in the Hellboy Universe the
Baba Yaga is known to be incredibly
powerful
she's a fearsome witch who's mostly
known for dealing a magic that involves
spirits and souls
she has an army of the undead at our
beck and call which could be pretty
interesting in the film if they show up
in the new trailer a woman named Alice
appears to be a field agent and the
employ of the BPRD
but most of what's been shown on the
movie there doesn't seem to be anything
too quirky or special about her that is
until she punches someone so hard their
spirit flies out of them there's a
chance this could have something to do
with the flashy appropriately BPRD
branded brass knuckles
she sports in the trailer there's also a
chance that this hints at a comic book
roots as a person deeply affected by and
connected to the Fae in the 1995 Hellboy
comic the corpse
Hellboy must rescue Alice as a baby
after she's kidnapped by the king of the
fairies after being saved one of the
fairies reveals to Hellboy that they
were going to raise Alice as her own
child because something has gone wrong
and fairies are no longer able to have
children in 2008 the Wild Hunt
Hellboy meets Alice again and remarks a
how young she looks even though decades
have passed indicating that her time
with the Fae has somehow altered her
through the effects of Nimmo waist
treachery Alice essentially becomes the
new queen of the fairies and struggles
to provide sanctuary for the fails the
world literally goes to hell
movie Alice may not end up having as
grand a role as she does in the comics
but this simple shot from the trailer at
least hints at a supernatural connection
for the character it's tough to tell if
the giant entity summoned by Nimmo way
is an aspect of the up drew jihad or
nuts but it's likely that the pale
skinless looking beast is meant to be
something similar to the ugh drew jihad
of the Hellboy comics the ugh drew jihad
are about as bad as bad guys gets they
represent one thing and one thing only
the
and of everything many of Hellboy's
villains have been working to summon the
ultra jihad in fact Hellboy Zone
summoning was a result of an OGG drew
jihad ritual gone wrong
whatever the massive entity that's
annihilating London in the trailer
actually is it's definitely linked to
the end times so much of what is shown
in the trailers hints of bad bad things
for our heroes including a first day two
gone wrong I'm a Capricorn in you will
this new film of everything that fans of
the character of been craving since the
last film Hellboy - the Golden Army that
came out in 2008 based on the details in
this trailer chances seem pretty good so
far
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]